I've been through a terrifying
experience I feared for my life second
by second minute by minute hour by hour
I'm incredibly grateful to the Italian
and UK authorities but all they have
done secured my safe release I have just
arrived home after four weeks of being
in Italy and I haven't had the time to
gather my thoughts I'm not at liberty to
say anything further until I have been
debriefed quite the you faithfully okay
that's the first time we're hearing from
this young woman suddenly a lot of
questions about this story bizarre and
disturbing no that's absolutely right I
mean you know one of the big questions
right now is once the suspect is saying
this is a 30-year old Polish man who as
you said was taken into custody after he
brought her to safety he seems to he has
a story that he's made 15 million euro
essentially selling trafficked women
just like her and the investigators want
to know if he's just made that up if
he's just concocted a story or if he's
really part of a very serious sex ring
trafficking women like that you know
essentially kidnapping them keeping them
captive and then putting them up for
auction he had with him when the police
found him some interesting documents
that would purport it to the fact that
he was advertising these women and that
he could deliver them anywhere in Europe
free of charge and the investigators
want to know if he's made that up or
she's really part of something bigger